foreign
[Music]
oh no
ah get off me you fool oh hey didn't
expect to find you here
and I really didn't expect to find her
here hey you listen to me bird the king
can never hear of this we are going to
forget this ever happened
are you listening to me yes sir you
won't tell him I won't tell him and I
will stay in one piece you got it got it
sorry what'd you say again yeah I'm a
dead crab
[Music]
what I can to live Where You Are
watch what I pay to stay here beside you
what would I do to save you
smiling at me
where would we walk
where would we run if we could stay all
day in the Sun
and trust you and me
be
Part of Your World
[Music]
he's alive and let the queen
I don't know where I don't know how
but I know something's starting right
now
watching you'll see
someday I'll be
[Music]
thank you
no
no no it's two too easy
she's already in love with the human
world and now she found her soul mate oh
oh racing some daddy finds out he's
gonna hit the surface
that little girl's gonna run straight
into my tentacles
and I'll use her as a prawn in my little
game
finally
the power away from Triton that should
have been mine all alone
as long as the king never finds out
everything will be all right
he never has to know she used that
precious siren song of hers to save a
human
I just have to find Ariel and get her
back home no
she was around here somewhere yeah this
must be it I just have to be firm with
her okay this is all just a passing pad
and in time she'll forget all about him
Ariel
Sebastian
is all it is
what are you doing with that that thing
isn't it beautiful
look at the longing in his eyes what do
you know about longing what is he doing
here it's from the Shipwreck I found
them at no man's refill but there's so
much more no no Ariel Eric child get
back here
you have to let go of this obsession
with humans
obsessed I may be crusty but I'm not
blind I saw you the night of the
Shipwreck what your father wants you to
stay as far away from them as possible
but why you know why we don't have to be
afraid of them I know that now Sebastian
if you had just seen it up there the
ship rode on the wind and they filled
the sky with fire okay okay listen to me
human world is a mess
if under the sea is better than anything
they got going on up there this seaweed
is always greener if somebody else is
up there but that is a big mistake just
look at the world around you right here
on the ocean floor such wonderful things
around you one more reason
[Music]
take it from me
slave away while we devoted full time to
floating under the sea
foreign
[Music]
see
under the seaweed bubbles
[Music]
thank you
today please
[Music]
foreign
hey Ariel
somebody got to nail that girl's fins to
the floor foreign